von balladen kommen meine liebe
zuschauer und somit den letzten die das
haben wir so unfassbar viele von euch
geschrieben dass ich unbedingt mal auf
das video ein tag im leben des reichsten
kindes der welt reagieren soll
also herzlich willkommen zu dem video
bei dem wir uns alle ziemlich pleite
fühlen werden gestatten das ist rashid
behaftet schon in seiner von der typ
hier ist vielleicht so zwölf jahre alt
hier gerade aber hat so viel geld auf
seinem bett sich um eine szene
mit zwölf jahren hätte ich mir nicht mal
seinen katzen verkaufen können obwohl es
einige kinder gibt die deutlich reichere
eltern haben als rashid so existiert
wohl niemand der in so jungen jahren
schon so verwöhnt ist okay also es geht
nicht darum dass seine familie die
reichsten der welt sind sondern dass er
selbst wohl schon als kind so viel geld
hat selbst die kinder von
multimilliardär bill gates oder von
warren buffett leben im vergleich noch
verhältnismäßig bescheiden ich sehe da
einfach nur unzählige limitiertes nicht
gerade
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich darauf
reagiere danach wieder rauszugehen
rashid erhält beispielsweise nur für
schuhe monatlich 5000 euro bekommt er
5000 dollar monatlich rashid besser
wurde am 15 januar zweck
[Musik]
sechs jahre jünger als ich
also momentan ist der 17
ja das macht es nicht besser mit meiner
laune die unternehmensgruppe steve davis
group ist heutzutage so groß und dass
die firmen aus fast allen bereichen wie
zb der luftfahrt der energiegewinnung
immobilien und aktien handel wie auch
technologie und bildung umfasst acht
krank also vor dem vater habe ich
unfassbaren respekt klar schlussendlich
er hat auch nur geerbt von seinem sohn
von seinem vater dann dementsprechend
aber trotzdem so was weiterzuführen
verlangt ja auch können et cetera aber
vor diesem kleinen kind namens rashid
werde hass oder wie er genau weiß ich
noch nicht genau was ich davon halten
soll
also ich würd mich scheiße fühlen wenn
meine eltern mir so viel geld geben
würden was andere nicht mal im monat
verdienen und dass es dann nur für meine
schuhe beispielsweise aber wir schauen
mal weiter aktuell besitzt sei auf ein
vermögen von unglaublichen firmen
4 milliarden
trotz seines jungen alters ist rashid
allerdings das wohl berühmteste mitglied
der gesamten familie auf instagram hat
er schon unfassbare 1,6 lang bis es
männer der in seiner bio stehen
du bist 17 die darf sich war geschäfte
führen aber wie wurde rashid eigentlich
so berühmt um es ganz kurz zu fassen
rashid ist berühmt weil er reich ist
glückwunsch da hätte ich jetzt aussagen
können unter dem namen money keks zeigt
er dann nach und nach immer mehr aus
seinem leben und hing auch immer man
muss auch allgemein mal schauen hier
wayne rooney 3 dollar sein
steve aoki bezahlte die dafür dass die
dann darum kommen oder denken die sich
ja klar ich würde gern mit einem 17
jährigen jungen kurz in dubai ist schön
rashid bell wassers tag beginnt für
gewöhnlich im luxus anwesen der familie
in drei wenn er dort aufwacht ist das
erste was rashid unternimmt nach seinen
zahlreichen haustiere gucken doch statt
hunden katzen und meerschweinchen
besitzt rashid zusammen mit seiner
familie einen ganzen zoo das ist
übrigens auch keine umschreibung sondern
er hat tatsächlich einen richtigen
echten zu
auf dem riesigen gelände befinden sich
in 34 gegenüber 140 verschiedene tiere
wir haben 140 tiere es ist so groß dass
raschid sogar mit einem golfcart zu den
einzelnen stationen fahren muss
da fragt man sich wirklich mehr normale
tiger und löwen sind auf dem zoogelände
häufig als ebenso wie gehen seltener
vogelarten affen und sogar bären
übrigens eine weitere besonderheit des
zoos ist dass raschid ein tieren promi
namen gegeben hat
fragt ihr euch noch war es mal so heißt
einer seiner tiger zb sie ein löwe und
ein affe perez hilton
warum auch nicht zwei orang utans hoffte
er gut ski und versace als eines der
reichsten kinder der welt unterscheidet
sich auf sein kleiderschrank sehr von
dem anderer menschen nur für seine
schuhe hat er ein ganzes zimmer
wahrscheinlich ist ein schutz immer
größer ist meine gesamte wohnung nur für
seine schuhe hat er ein ganzes zimmer
das sich in einem eigenen gebäude mitten
im zoo gelände befindet also nicht ein
eigenes zimmer für seine schuhe das
zimmer befindet sich sogar in seinem
eigenen haus für seine kleidung mitten
in seinem zoo ich habe eine wohnung
seines nica sammlung hat einen
gesamtwert von über einer million dollar
ganz cool meine sorge
doch kannst du mir dann vielleicht neues
paar socken kaufen danke er können wir
aber erst mal zu seinem schulalltag
nachdem sich rachid umgezogen hat wird
er zur schule gefahren er besuchte die
renommierte international school of arts
and sciences in du ganz kurz ich dachte
krieg privatunterricht
in einen zoo und eine million euro
sneaker aber geht auf eine normale
schule wort andere normale menschen
hingehen
das ist ja unmenschlich da die schule
sehr hohe gebühren für eine aufnahme
verlangt sintra schied mitschüler häufig
ebenfalls sehr vermögend einer seiner
besten freunde erfährt so zb auch ein
lamborghini bei uns in der schule ging
es darum haye hat ein fahrrad licht
dastehen
dynamo trainer ich bin gott und
gepäckträger bei denen bobby höher
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
privatbesitz der 17-jährige ein ferrari
f 12 berlinetta
an alle die sich mit autos bzw
exotischen supercups jetzt nicht
unbedingt so krank auskennen googelt
einfach mal ferrari f 12 berlinetta ich
meine klar im ferrari 812 und dann noch
mit novitec oder keine ahnung hat oder
in ein lager das ist nochmal ein
stückchen krasser finde ich aber mit 17
jahren ist selbst zwölf berliner
deutschland ganz in ordnung bild der
wagen mehrere hunderttausend dollar
kostet und rashid kaum zeit hat den
ferrari zu nutzen dass dies nicht das
einzige auto in seiner sammlung
er hat noch mehr so umfasst sein
fuhrpark noch einen rolls royce ein
hammer und zahlreiche weitere fahrzeuge
fahren kann er die autos übrigens nicht
da dies in dubai erst ab 18 jahren
erlaubt ist
[Musik]
hammer
heuer darf die karte nicht fahren laut
rashid kommen alle stars bei ihren
aufenthalten immer erst zu ihm weil sie
die tiger in seinem zu sehen und
streicheln wollen die
die kommen rum wegen den tigern wenn er
nicht das nächste mal dabei bin kann ich
auch mal den tiger streicheln bei dir
oder blogger die hand ab alter hängt
öfter mit youtuber leuten voll ab und
einer seiner besten freunde ist move log
der wohl bekannteste blogger aus ganz
dubai nur das ist doch krank was er für
ein leben führt oder in einem interview
erklärte er dass es sein größter traum
wäre eines tages mal basketballstar
michael jordan zu treffen
ich glaube ich glaub ich glaube dass das
wird dennoch schaffen
doch all das ist für den 17 jährigen nur
freizeit denn abseits der schule ist
rashid auch als unternehmer tätig rashid
es mit 17 jahren als unternehmer tätig
da will ich jetzt mal was der macht er
nutzte seine unglaubliche social media
reichweite aus um eine eigene marke zu
etablieren unter seinem namen man eex
betreibt er inzwischen ein eigenes
klamotten label ich habe auch den luca
shop.de trotzdem würde ich mich jetzt
nicht so als unternehmer oder
international young business menden oder
so tatsächlich gelang es ihm durch seine
marke bereits finanziell immer
unabhängiger von seinem vater zu werden
schätzungsweise drei millionen dollar
soll er bereits mit dem verkauf eigene
klamotten verdient haben
ich würde den lukas oder mal in deine
hände geben er dreht youtube videos mit
seinen promi-gästen und hat vor allem
durch placement auf seinem instagram
account ein zusätzliches einkommen
ok also schlussendlich muss man sagen er
macht eigentlich ähnlich bissen mehr
oder weniger wie ich also ich habe auch
meine merchandise shop auf der anderen
seite social media etc
wo ich auch manchmal places machen
cetera allerdings hat er ein bisschen
reichere rundum verhält für einmal nicht
am arbeiten ist und auch keine schule
hat macht rashid auch gerne mal urlaub
seine familie besitzt luxusanwesen in
der ganzen welt anderem auch in den usa
angereist wird daher immer per flugzeug
im privatjet des vaters manchmal aber
auch auf linienflügen in der ersten
klasse ja klar flug kann da auch schon
mal 30.000 dollar
das ist so das ding was ich nicht
verstehe
selbst wenn ich der multimilliardäre
welt mensch der welt but what ever wäre
würde ich trotzdem nicht 30.000 dollar
für einen flug bezahlen wo ich auch
einfach weniger bezahlen könnte ich
glaube bis ins glas denn das first class
ticket halt 3000 kostet wird business
class zu 5000 kosten würde ich immer
business festnehmen weil du siehst ja
nie länger als irgendwie zwölf stunden
und da will ich mir nachher mal denken
hey 25.000 euro gespart und ebenfalls
aber gut ich glaube wenn du vier
milliarden euro auf dem konto hat und
wenn dein sohn auch schon über drei
millionen euro verdient hat dann ist es
noch eine ganz andere liga und
vielleicht kann ich das noch nicht so
richtig einschätzen dann etwas das bei
dimension sind aber ich habe da auf
jeden fall respekt vor was der vater
erreicht hat was der großvater erreicht
hat was die sich aufgebaut haben
finde den lebenstil allerdings sehr
bedenklich und verschwenderisch gerade
wenn es um den zoo geht und um eine
million euro schuhe
da kann man das geld auch sinnvoller
verwenden finde ich allerdings ist das
nur meine meinung und wenn ihr eine
andere meinung hat oder meine meinung
eventuell sogar teil dann könnt ihr mir
ja gern mal und in die kommentare
schreiben das zudem gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da wenn euch
meine reaktion auf das reichste kind der
welt gefallen hat und abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
noch kein teil der lokalseite
da würde ich mich darüber freuen und
verpasste keine videos mehr können wir
aber auch gerne in kommentare schreiben
welches video sie als nächstes reagieren
soll
und ich fühle mich unfassbar pleite
[Musik]